[Music]
holy [ __ ]
oh my god it looks as though
some pro players have been banned by
volvo dazed swag
azk steel r i p
ladies and gentlemen r.i.p i think this
kid
has insane talent and they have a very
sad history that he can't compete
anymore
maybe it'd be great to have my band and
i and i know uh
i know he would use that second chance
to uh prove
the community wrong he sat in the middle
and you sit next to me and jordan you
just know like
the kid just [ __ ] wants to play more
than anything potentially could one day
be a great player in
all of counter-strike braxton pierce was
supposed to be nacs's next great hope
instead he became the region's greatest
tragedy
a burgeoning star lost to one single
mistake
but now after five years of sitting on
the sidelines
brax is back but not in cs go
sisters are [ __ ] amazing dude these
guys [ __ ] pre-fired angels that don't
exist
so as you guys might have noticed
spotlight looks different that's because
much like the rest of the world we're
doing
our part to prevent the spread of kovid
19 which means bringing you that same
great content just
from the comfort of our own homes so you
know stay safe and wash your hands
now let's get back into the story
formerly known as swag
brax was once hailed as na's next cs
prodigy
on quad oh what shut up swag
my god
holy [ __ ] he played cs all his life
starting all the way back with 1.6 he
spent the early years of cs go climbing
the n a ranks
jumping from team to team before
eventually joining eye by power
this is the point in time where i buy
power just take over swag in the middle
gets one more
to his score line i think he's one kill
away from 30. if you just take down eco
but skadoodle
will steal it away and that's dust2 in
favor of ibuypower
just like that i buy power quickly
established themselves as na's best team
with brax considered one of the team's
biggest stars
but that star quickly fell in august of
2014.
round one is going live now netkill
guides versus i buy power
in the group stage of sibo season 5 i
buy power through an online
match and while that match was pretty
meaningless
the consequences changed brax and his
teammates lives
forever we have some interesting
information
it looks as though some pro players have
been banned by volvo
could deborn casey foster dazed swag
azk steel r i p
ladies and gentlemen rip at just 18
years old
brax had his pro counter-strike career
cut short by
valve na's next great star banned from
competition
brax kept playing cs go hoping to one
day get unbanned
and he wasn't alone the cs go community
rallied behind him starting the free
brax movement
and in 2017 it looked like brax might
finally be getting another chance
yo listen have you checked the computer
lately
you're unbanned bro congratulations
shut the [ __ ] up i swear to god
you're unbanned from esl i swear to not
go check
in with the new sanction structure
i'm super happy for you guys i'm super
happy i gotta go i'm gonna put uh
go stream right now and you'll get a
hundred thousand viewers guaranteed
yeah host peace everyone thought that
esl unbanning him meant that valve would
follow suit
that soon brax could compete at a major
again but sadly
that never happened sure brass could
play in some tournaments now
just not the ones that mattered most so
for the next four years
he stayed trapped in the lower rungs of
cs playing on teams that had no shot at
making a major
but in october brax saw a way out of
that hole project a
is our character-based tactical shooter
it's competitive
it has precise gun play it's set on a
beautiful near future earth
and it has a lethal cast of characters
each with their own unique abilities
this is our take on a competitive
shooter like most people who watched
riot games as project a or valorent
trailer
brax was mesmerized and not just because
the shooter looked like it could be
right up his alley
this game could mean big things for him
in his career
valerian represents a chance for brax to
compete in a world where there's no i
buy power
no match fixing and most importantly no
bans
there's no shortage of people claiming
that they're going to go pro and
valorent
a game that's not even out yet but brax
he did the impossible
by signing with t1 brax has officially
become valorent's first pro
he turned a meme into reality but memes
aside
valerians probably brax's last shot he's
no longer the teenage prodigy that
everyone marveled over
he's almost 24 forced to waste some of
his prime
years in banned purgatory get [ __ ]
days
sorry bro you're the ringleader you
should burn and i'm just so sad that you
[ __ ] brought swagging this [ __ ] with
you
that you took advantage of a [ __ ]
young star that was that had everything
ahead of him
and that he could he could have [ __ ]
gone on to become one of the best north
american players of all time
to [ __ ] dominate worldwide and you
ruined that so
[ __ ] you all we can do is wait and see
if csgo's lost prodigy
can make up for lost time thanks for
watching
if you want more content like this hit
the sub button and ring that
notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages